look again the Marvel Cinematic Universe
has more skin crawling Horrors than you
might remember
werewolf by night is an adventure in
full-blown horror this blood-splattered
Halloween special even peso marched
early 1930s movie Monsters like the
Wolfman and Dracula in its opening scene
a standout production boasting
incredible effects it shot entirely in
black and white this is gorgeous and
also makes a sickening blood and gore
more palatable so even younger audiences
can enjoy the gruesome Thrills on offer
decides
House Rules
werewolf by night is the MCU director of
your debut of esteemed composer Michael
jokino who also arranged The Haunting
score his distinctive style compliments
star guyo Garcia Bernal perfectly as
jokino detailed in an interview with the
discussing film werewolf by Knights is
practically bursting with practical
effects this honors the horror movies of
old and also allows Bernal skills to
shine through tokino remarked it's
always fun to watch a CG monster but for
this this was such a personal story that
I wanted someone real someone that when
I looked in their eyes I was looking
into the eyes of a human behind that
monster such death of humanity makes a
werewolves ferocious Carnage even more
gripping you truly see the rage and
bernal's eyes this grounds the
unforgettable scene of his Slaughter
strobe like lighting briefly allows the
audience a second to breathe before more
vicious slashes ensue the moment is made
even more scary when blood is strewn
across the camera's lens
Moon Knight starts sending shivers down
and viewers back in his earliest
episodes without much insight into the
Egyptian god konshu fans are left to
quake in the shadow of his mysterious
power this lack of knowledge extends to
our leader Stephen Grant which is
actually only one of the many confusing
identities our protagonist possesses
Grant is often bewildered by the strange
events occurring around him which
translates into the audience feeling
equally perplexed and oftentimes scared
out of their wits konshu's pursuit of
Stephen is an especially spine tingling
moment as the god displays a Relentless
willingness to frighten the gift shop
employee until he complies with his
wishes in a dimly lit storage facility
konshu appears to Grant seeking to merge
with him and become the titular Moon
Knight he frighteningly materializes
between flickering lights before
beginning his Pursuit down a long dark
hallway this sends Grant off screaming
but no matter how fast or far he runs he
can't escape konshu doesn't give up
easily this scene features an
interesting filmmaking detail used in
older horror films its highlights
Grant's horrified screen with a freeze
frame reaction shot it also illuminates
Khan Shu in bone chilling detail as he
Towers over Grant his voice booming in
the close confines these Eerie details
set Moonlight apart from the rest of the
MCU as a unique and ghastly journey into
brain bending horror
when Loki began his run on Disney plus
it quickly consumed fans with new
Concepts worlds and details to discuss
variants of our favorite characters
wacky alternate realities and the Grand
and glittering Multiverse are all on
offer here and then when Loki season 1
comes to its end it reveals one more
trick of its sleeve so it's all a game
it's all
a manipulation episode 6 for all time
always contains a breathtaking surprise
the Casual reveal of Kang in variant
form this iteration refers to himself as
he who remains he informs Loki and his
sarcastic blonde Varian Sylvie at his
death will bring an even stronger form
to life who is far more fearsome comic
fans shoulder with the realization that
this will finally bring forth Kang the
Conqueror one of the Marvel universe's
most formidable villains
[Music]
feels like a fresh start
when Sylvie gives in to her anger and
stabs he who remains she fulfills his
prophecy and sets this variant form free
his death allows the birth of the
Conqueror who will eventually stand
poised to decimate the MCU this makes he
who remains display of Glee even more
harrowing he's stabbed and he's happy
about it
hounds by experienced horror Visionary
Sam Raimi doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness mixes a usual fun
of the MCU with a few genuine scares
honestly I hope not here the
grief-stricken Scarlet Witch who has
become consumed by the malevolent
darkhold doesn't just go bad she heads
into ultimate villain territory
and wonder possesses a variant form of
herself in an effort to infiltrate that
variance universe as an unpardonable sin
against the Multiverse but it's when she
kills Marvel's heroic Illuminati that
things get dark Wanda Begins by
imploding black Bolt's brain by using
his abilities gruesomely against him she
then unleashes more chaos by unraveling
Mr Fantastic slicing Captain Carter in
half with her own shield and crushing
Captain Marvel beneath an enormous
statue but Wanda saves her most vicious
murder for last professor Charles Xavier
in his iconic yellow hover chair
announces that enough is enough the two
sidekicks proceed to face off on the
mental plane Xavier attempts to rescue
the possessed wonder who's trapped in
rubble he gets closer and closer to
reaching her but then the Sinister
wander leaps out of a cloud of red smoke
and snaps his neck killing him instantly
this brutal death subclose nature makes
it all the more arresting
the wildly imaginative animated Disney
plus series what if it takes audiences
to the complex layers of the Multiverse
since when did Dan did they fight like
that the premise sets it up to be a
mostly inconsequential narrative which
transports our favorite heroes and
villains to new and exciting universes
the mysterious interdimensional being
known as The Watcher is our guide to it
all explaining the stories of these
varying characters and universes he's
safely obscured from the proceedings as
an observer and narrator bounds to
monitor their choices without ever
interfering but this playful idea enters
scary new territory when it takes
classic Avengers villain Ultron Down A
New Path where he not only successfully
merges with vision's body but also
obtains all six Infinity Stones from
here I can see everything no one can
stop me now ultron's heightened
abilities give him or inspiring power
he's so mighty he ascends to a new level
of Consciousness which allows him to
hear the watch's narration in one
shocking moment he becomes able to see
through the story itself turns his head
and locks eyes with the Watcher this
terrifies The Watcher to is very core
audiences sympathize it also feels like
Ultron sees the viewers with his
unflinching gaze Ultron is rarely
scarier than he is in this moment when
he becomes powerful enough to transcend
fiction itself
Wanda's dark hole trip and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
transforms a reality bending Adventure
into an implacable Revenge driven
god-like monster a Scarlet Witch's Dark
Turn showcases an abundance of grisly
new powers which are all put to use in
her Unstoppable pursuit of
dimension-hopping teenager America
Chavez one ability is put on
particularly flashy display when wander
uses Reflections in water to escape
Doctor Strange's Infamous mirror
Dimension director Sam Raimi builds a
suspense with agonizing Peak as
Wonderful's defenseless guards to their
Doom through reflective puddles
she's using the reflections cover them
this gruesome campaign of Slaughter only
ends when she sickeningly contorts her
body through a reflective gong when she
emerges she's broken and torn crawling
on limbs I've been the wrong way but
then glowing with power she wrenches her
bones back into place men's the cracks
in her flesh and stands up straight like
the best horror movie Monsters she is
inescapable there's something truly
terrifying about watching Wanda pull
herself forward with an evidently broken
spine the fact that this is swiftly
topped by the sight of her forcing said
spine back into place says it all
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness is a Non-Stop Thrill Ride of
gory imagery terrifying creatures and
utterly Unstoppable evil this is never
more clear than when strange possesses
his variance corpse and launches himself
into battle
who said they had to be living this
reanimation puts Doctor Strange in an
entirely new light and some benser films
horror Bonafide zombie strange is gross
his face is eaten away with rut his
limbs move like those of an old puppet
and his skin has grown gray and pallid
then he UPS the anti considerably by
weaving The Souls of the Damned who have
come to condemn him for possessing the
variance body into an infernal cloak
which allows them to reach the battle
director samremi's ability to
incorporate a certain level of camp with
utterly jaw-dropping horror makes his
vision of an undead dog to strange into
one of the coolest and most horrifying
things to ever come out of the MCU
that wasn't a dream
Marvel's what if adapts one of the most
frightening versions of the Avengers by
tackling Robert kirkman's Infamous
Marvel Zombies comics in his standout
episode what if zombies this installment
features a deadly plague which infects a
superhero team monstrously transforming
them into flesh-eating zombies
surprisingly the episode entirely
Embraces the comics gritty celebration
of Gore blood is spilled noses rut off
and teeth are bad that was your friend
sorry about that
about the zombies on the most horrifying
part of the episode it's a disturbing
way the Avengers turn on each other even
without the virus vision is the main
antagonist of this installment he holds
black panther captive as a food source
for his beloved this stunning
realization is truly summer turning just
the thought of a zombified Wonder
consuming the wakandan Royal is awful
the chaos magic wielder has been turned
into a flesh-eating corpse who still has
distressing access to her powers but
seeing t'challa's terrified face is way
way worse
One Division incorporates a myriad of
Television Aesthetics over the course of
its run from Cherry mid-century family
hijinks to The Lovable dysfunctional
approach of 90s sitcoms but things
plummet into horror when Wanda turns
around to answer a question from vision
and is met with the awful reality behind
her hex she doesn't see her loving
husband she sees his corpse reanimates
it to her will this moment alludes to a
Reclamation of vision's body which we
see in subsequent episodes wander has
seen this face before and she hasn't
managed to block it out entirely
no we can't
it also portrays wonders fracturing
mental state which is weakening her
spell this jump scare is a quietly
forceful way of making us and wonder
face reality if only for a moment vision
is an empty shell sustained only by
wonders abilities which finally unravel
in the finale
after massacring the Illuminati and
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness the Scarlet Witch continues her
undeterred Pursuit Of America Chavez
this sends the movie into truly classic
horror territory wander is the invomable
monster relentlessly chasing the hapless
victims who just can't seem to shake her
things get especially horrifying when
the Scarlet Witch chases Our Heroes for
an industrial tunnel she rips through
door after door limping from her
injuries this imagery brings ultron's
earliest form to mind he too twitched
and struggled to communicate his message
she's also Barefoot and covered in blood
rendering her a truly Primal image of
fear wonders glowing red eyes convey not
only her massive power but also her
intense rage the Scarlet wages
channeling pure Fury as she wrenches
open barrier after barrier to some fans
this makes her an irredeemable villain
to others it's a horrible yet
sympathetic act but it shows are scared
of Living Daylights out of just about
everyone
[Music]
I warned you in Spider-Man far from home
the emotional return to the MCU after
the Monumental events of Avengers end
game Peter Parker struggles to cope in a
Tony cyclist World while traveling
through Europe on a class trip he
encounters the manipulative Mysterio
this fiend traps Spider-Man in a
dizzying dream sequence where he comes
face to face with his unresolved fears
they take the gut-wrenching form of Tony
circane corpse complete with a cracked
Iron Man helmet and a swarm of spiders
that crawl out of his skull this
unsettling image Peaks our most morbid
interest but it also offers bizarre and
potent closure we see Tony's death and
funeral in Avengers end game yet it
doesn't seem quite real that he won't be
returning for another film his startling
resurrection and Spider-Man far from
home makes it clear that Tony Stark is
really truly and completely gone and
both Peter and the audience must find a
way to cope
if you were good enough
maybe Tony would still be alive
Marvel's Avengers Age of Ultron
introduces the titular Android in a
truly Dreadful way coming at the tail
end of one of the team's more
light-hearted moments a victory party
held at Avengers Tower the festivities
are abruptly cut short by ear piercing
feedback Ultron stumbles from the
laboratory a broken puppet newly free of
strings his first actors to take over
Tony's Sentry robots invade The Avengers
compound and challenge Earth's Mightiest
Heroes in their own home ultron's
immense power can be felt even through
the pathetically convulsing body
inhabits he derives The Avengers as
pitiful puppets and able to challenge
his might as he struggles to hold his
Machinery together you might find
yourself shifting uncomfortably in your
seats there's just something about his
Eerie movement
no strings and zombies this line still
manages to chill the blood even when you
know Ultron doesn't get his way it's one
of the best bits of dialogue in the
entire MCU and its scariest ever moment